what I was going to do was I was going
to talk a little bit just start off with
a little bit of an introduction to kegel
talk a little bit about some of the
couple of lessons that we've learned
that we think are interesting and
hopefully useful then finish off by
talking a little bit about some of the
things that we're working on that we're
excited about and some of the the future
of where where where we're taking the
company and then I'd love I don't plan
to use the full hour I'd really like you
know we see a lot of keggle and I feel
like I feel like you know I'd love you
to think of think of questions or things
to think of things that that that you
know we might have been that that are
interesting to you that we might have an
interesting perspective on so certainly
will leave plenty of time for Q&A so
please please do think of things you
want to ask as I go along so just before
I start show of hands who's heard of
Kegel before all right so good portion
of the room that's good and it was going
to ask how many of you have downloaded a
data set in the last year from Cagle
still a good proportion how many of you
have submitted to competitions in the
last year all right nice so I'm not
going to I'm going to I'm going to
really whiz through the the waters Cagle
because it seems like there's some
pretty good familiar feel me already in
the road for anyone who's not familiar
just very quickly I wear a platform for
machine learning competition so what
we'll do is we'll take data sets from
companies we put them up and an
researchers will put them up on the web
and we have a community at least the
top-level metric is around about 330,000
data scientists signed up to cargill we
split data sets into two halves a
training data set where we give people
access to the answer's no data set is
really this simple this is a toy example
but at a training data set where we give
people the answers and we a test data
set where we live hold the answers and
so people will download the data sets
and they'll upload their submissions and
we score people on a on a live
leaderboard based on how they're
performing now it's incredibly it's
really interesting the impact of putting
people showing people how they're
performing on a live leaderboard it
turns out
be a really strong motivator and the
example I like to give so this is this
is just my favorite example because I
think it has some some nice some nice
sort of story elements to it but all the
competitions look exactly the same so
what happens is somebody makes the first
entry so this is a very very early
competition that we did with nasa's jet
propulsion lab in Pasadena California
and they wanted to is an image problem
they wanted to take basically images of
galaxies and measure very precisely the
ellipticity of those images and if you
can do that it turns out you can back
out that the dark matter distribution of
the universe I remember being on a call
with the host of this competition and
you've sort of explaining the physics to
us and at one point he said oh and this
requires a simple a simple application
of general relativity which is I would
say that's where he lost me but he
actually lost me well before that anyway
the so the problem was nicely specified
and it turned out that the first entry a
very strong entry was made by
glaciologist uncle Martin O'Leary he was
at at the time at Cambridge University
and he'd in this case the y-axis is
Error the lower the better and the x
axis is time and so this problem was
taking taking taking data from
telescopes that were pointed up at up at
galaxies and measuring the ellipticity
well it turns out that in Martin's
research what he did was he would take
satellite images look that looked down
at Earth and he would measure the the
edges of glaciers so it turns out that
he was able to make a pretty quick break
through on this problem because he his
research involved doing very similar
things and he was very happy and one of
the reasons he was very happy is because
he had done about a decade's worth of
his his his algorithm and out done a
decade's worth of work done but in the
Astronomy community so it was actually
this some this blog post was put up on
the White House Office of Science and
Technology Policy blog they wrote that
the world's brightest physicists had
been working on this problem for a while
and that in less than a week Martin
O'Leary a PhD student in vallejo ology
could outperform the state-of-the-art
algorithm I should have actually pulled
out the tweet but he was he he he
actually he got onto Twitter and he said
not that I'm bragging or nothing but the
White House has just compared me to
Einstein and Newton so he was very yes
it was really very happy there's you can
see that they explained that the
background of this this problem they
talked about Einstein's theory of
relativity and Newton's law of gravity's
day he was very happy but not for very
long because somebody passed him and
then he passed them and they passed him
and he passed them and they keep passing
each other until and those of you who
have competed will have seen this effect
you get a whole lot of people sort of
clustering on on some level of accuracy
what's going on is that there's a limit
to how much you can get out of the data
set you get to the point where you've
sort of extracted everything out of the
data set it's very interesting if you we
we have the as you as you can as you
know we have the answers on the
submission files and if you compare the
submission files from the first from the
people who are all sort of grouped at
around the same score they're typically
all getting pretty much the same stuff
right in the same stuff wrong and so the
the intuition there is is is signal and
there's noise in a data set and you get
to the point a competition is a very
powerful way to get to the point we've
really extracted all the value out of a
data set when you get to the limit of
what's possible before I go under there
any questions around anything I've
spoken about so far oh sorry oh who won
yeah actually really I said that this
this the reason I always give this
example is because it has a lot of nice
yeah nice storytelling aspects except
for the fact that the people who won
ended up being particle physicists and
cosmologists not so so Martin did not
end up winning just despite actually
catalyzing a lot of oh yeah i forgot to
mention this so one thing that's really
interesting is that when somebody makes
a breakthrough almost immediately other
people replicate that score and they're
not they're very rarely the winner the
person who makes a breakthrough is very
rarely sharing what actually caused that
breakthrough but
just the yeah just seeing what's
possible makes it so it's that we use we
like to talk about the Roger Bannister
effect after the guy who first broke the
four-minute mile so you know 19 I forget
what year nineteen fifty-four around
then the world record for the mile was
four minutes in one second and it had
been for ten ten years but then Roger
Bannister broke it and and 46 days later
John Landy outperformed him there's
something about just you know when
somebody makes it be breakthrough it
makes others try and you know it makes
them no longer just tuned hyper
parameters but it makes them try much
more bigger things and so you know
Martin's breakthroughs ended up
catalyzing good performances in other
people from other people question
yeah so typically um so yeah I'll repeat
the question that's probably a good
practice and sets moretz right no I'll
company will discuss later so the
question was if if we took the first
second third fourth fifth placed entries
and we ensemble them together would we
get an even better score than we then we
then we get from the individual models
it actually turns out that the winners
are typically ensemble lling sometimes
they're they're different teams that are
coming together and so at this point
once you're at the limit of what's
possible it's really the case that
ensemble doesn't make much of a
difference at all yeah question yeah you
do see a false floor on occasions where
your little plateau there and then and
then you'll see another dip later and
the way we know whether it's a false
floor or a real dip is by again
comparing the correlations between the
entries from first second third fourth
if the correlation is not terribly
higher than we know they're still more
to find in that in that data set any any
other questions or if not I will
continue okay I'll pause it a couple of
points as I go through so and continue
asking questions so a couple of things
that we have done that I'm particularly
proud of relatively early on the Hewlett
Foundation came to us with a problem
around taking high school essays and
trying to grade them algorithmically and
so we had seven seven different seven
different essay questions each of them
had been graded by at least two teachers
and sometimes a third if there was quite
a lot of disagreement between the two
teachers and the idea was to to build an
algorithm that could match the average
grade of the two teachers and this was I
think we did this in 2012 or 2013 and
when the Hewlett Foundation brought us
this problem we actually thought it was
probably unlikely to be possible it
certainly sounded like something that
that really pushed the limit of what was
possible it turned out that if you
looked at the
see between the two teachers and the
discrepancy between either teacher and
the winning algorithm those
discrepancies were about the same so the
you know what we learn from that or the
surprising thing that came out of that
is it actually is at least when you have
a large number of essays to train on all
with the same question it actually is
possible to to build an algorithm that
can grade high school essays and so this
was a particular piece of work that we
internally were particularly proud of
although that being said we we did we
got a lot of negative press for this
about robo readers and teachers being
replaced and things like that in fact we
have one journalist who even asked us if
we could grade her her article for her
and then more recently we did some work
that I think think again internally
we're very proud of with the Mayo Clinic
so this was taking EEG signals and
trying to predict an hour before
somebody had a sit well in we actually
started with dogs because dogs have
seizures more often than human epileptic
dogs have seizures more often than
humans so it's much easier to put
together a training set if you with dogs
so what we were trying to do is predict
an hour in advance whether or not a dog
was going to have a seizure and it
turned out we could predict with the
eighty-two percent accuracy and then we
did a follow-up piece of work again with
the Mayo Clinic and the University of
Pennsylvania this time using humans
rubber band other than dogs so again
another run I think you know a lot of
what we're starting to see is medicine
has a lot of interesting unstructured
data and medical diagnosis we see as
sort of a really promising area for
machine learning I think you know like
we saw with the the essay grading one of
the big block is is just the the
acceptance societal acceptance is really
a big issue any questions I was going to
move on and talk a little bit about some
of the things that we've learned but i'm
happy to pause in case there's any any
questions before i do okay
so we have cobblers an hour worked with
around about 25 fortune 500 companies as
mentioned we have a community of 320,000
data scientists ranked from one to three
hundred and twenty thousand based on
performances in competitions so we've
seen a lot we're now at the point where
people are submitting about a hundred
and forty thousand 135,000 machine
learning models to goggle competitions a
month so you know as data sciences is
becoming a bigger thing as the quality
of competitions that we're launching is
becoming better we're seeing more and
more and more activity on Cargill and
and you know we're also learning some
pretty interesting lessons one of the
one of the lessons that I think came
through pretty early for us was the
importance of feature engineering
feature engineering does does much more
to win competitions than does algorithms
one example nice intuitive example that
i'm going to give it's actually not one
of our competitions but i like the
examples i'm going to give it is from
the netflix prizes anyone heard of the
neff next books far as you know most
people have so this was for those who
haven't was a competition run by netflix
to improve their recommendation
algorithm one of the things that one of
the a pretty significant breakthrough
when when when it looked like the
competition had reached a plateau one of
the significant breakthroughs was when
somebody discovered that if you watch
two movies in a day you're going to
write the second movie differently to
how you would have rated it if it was
the first movie that you would watch
because that's not about better
algorithms that's about sort of clever
to think about generating features
similarly one of our competitions again
another one I like talking about because
it's easy to relate to us around
predicting whether it a castle that a
secondhand auction was likely to be a
good buyer or lemon and what somebody
found was was they they found that the
car color had actually quite a big
impact on whether a car was likely to be
reliable or not and in particular what
they found was that unusual color cars
were more likely to be reliable
standard color cars and so what they how
they were able to discover this was
first of all creating doing feature
engineering well creativity matters a
lot so you've got to be able to generate
lots and lots and lots of different
ideas so dark color cars versus like
color cars maybe the assumption is that
dark color cars are harder to spot at
night they're in accidents more often
and the unusual color cars i mentioned
red color cars because they're more
likely to be sports cars things you know
generating lots and lots of different
features and not just not just not just
taking the data as is but that creating
synthetic lots of interesting synthetic
variables and so that that teac takes
creativity then in order to be able to
once you've generated lots of ideas you
need to be able to test them in robust
ways so good suffering engineering
practices like version control really
help you and sort of sort of test in in
more of a scientific way and be able to
track the results of tests that you that
you conduct and then the final arm the
final thing is the final important skill
as far as being able to do feature
engineering well is is good statistical
goods using good statistical methods to
make sure you're not overfitting make
sure that that your cross validating
appropriately make sure that the effects
that you're finding are real effects you
know we one of the one of the things
that we see so so often in kerrville
competitions is that people over fit to
the public leaderboard so they'll think
they're you know somebody will be in
first place and then we should explain
this what we do is we have to test data
sets on Cargill so the representation I
gave you before was a little bit of a
simplified one actually we have to test
data sets and we'll show people's
performance on a live leaderboard then
we'll throw that throw that leaderboard
away and will retest people on a second
test data set and if you if your google
for overfitting you'll see probably a
bunch of people have written the blog
post with the title saying something
like how I lost four hundred places in
one second and what happened is you know
the deadline for the competition ended
there in first place that they had over
fitted to the public leaderboard
so when we switched over to the the
actual leaderboard that dropped four
hundred places and now to what is an
incredibly effective way to learn the
lesson of overfitting when you've put a
lot of work and you think you're doing
incredibly well and then and then you
find that you haven't performed so well
and an interesting lady the frequency
with which we see overfitting to the
public leader board which is actually
sort of relatively hard not relatively
hard to do but it's it's it's it's
harder to do than if you had access to
the test data set makes me sort of just
you know makes me always want to get the
let the reminder to people that when
they're working with data sets where you
have access to the full test data set
make sure you really are protecting
against overfitting because it's you
know it's it's endemic in a situation
where we think where it's actually quite
hard to do and it makes me wonder just
how in demic it is when when when data
scientists have access to the full test
data set question so the reason we have
two different leader boards is because
as the competition's going up going
along you're getting feedback from the
public leader board you're getting
feedback from the public leader board
and so what happens is you're just so
you're getting eighty-five percent
correct so it's miss classification
error is the objective is that is the
metric and what you what you might do is
just say you're in first place you might
just tune you're just sort of tune your
hyper parameters and just try and get
from 85 to 86 287 just optimized for
pushing up that score and what you're
really doing is you're not you're
creating a an algorithm that works very
well just for that leaderboard data set
but doesn't generalize well which is not
terribly useful any any other questions
I would actually say so the question was
how often does it happen that the person
who was leading the competition doesn't
end up winning unfortunately well as our
competitions becoming more and more and
more popular the SL competitions are
becoming more more more and more popular
we have more and more more and more
people entering them and so what ends up
happening is very often the difference
when first second third and fourth is
not statistically significant and so it
actually ends up being a lottery whether
you end up finishing first or fifth so
the it's it's actually becoming more
yeah it's becoming more of an issue just
as as kerrville becomes more popular one
thing I will say is that Steven who just
asked the question his daughter is
responsible for the number of
competitions that we posted on cable so
I think if to the extent that um we are
working to address this problem so we
will have have a wider spread of
competitions hopefully over there over
the next six months so that we don't
have you know three thousand entrance /
competition and it isn't a lottery as to
who wins question the back can you
repeat the question you mind repeating
the question
I mean cross-validation so the question
was that what are the regularization
techniques that people are using in
order to make sure that they don't over
fit so cross validation is sort of a one
that's applicable across all techniques
and if done well that that should get
you most of the way most of the way to
where you need to be to prevent against
overfitting
are you saying what sort of what sort of
problems is it possible to get higher
accuracy and what sort of problems is it
so do man repeating right yeah so
they're there so the question was there
are some problems of machine learning
does a good job of and some some
problems that machine learning doesn't
do a good job of and I actually think is
so we I'll give you some examples I
don't know that I'm yet in the position
where so because of the fact that people
get to the limit of what's possible on a
data set we we sort of have a good data
set as to you know what machine learning
can do well and what machine learning
can't do well um I don't know that we've
really sort of synthesized systematic
learnings that we can share back one
thing we can say is that there's a lot
of excitement around convolutional
neural networks or deep learning at the
moment that really is leading to that
really is winning competitions and
improving what you can do with images
and and natural language processing so
that is improved the you know the what's
possible with those sorts of problems
and you know we've had problems where
we've literally not been able to make
any progress whatsoever someone was
taking Twitter data and trying to trying
to figure out somebody's personality
from the air tweets you know whether the
psychopathic or whether then Isis is
doing on it turns out that we got no
zero signal out of that data set on the
flip side we had a problem which sounded
like a pretty hard problem to take
basically sound recordings from the
ocean and figure out try and detect
different types of Wales and actually
that was possible with 100% accuracy so
just giving you saw the range of
something that turned out to be
impossible and something that turned out
to be well totally one hundred percent
doable correctly
it's a great question so have we tried
to take a problem from two years ago and
rerunning it today and see whether the
the limit changes we have not it's a
really nice idea particularly in some of
the areas where we've seen I dig
learning really make a difference it's a
nice nice experiment question say that
again sorry yeah so the question was is
it sometimes the case that the model
that ends up winning a competition ends
up being very complex and doesn't end up
getting deployed and so this was what
happened with the netflix prize where
they ran it for two years in the winning
solution was was it was an ensemble of
seven or eight hundred different models
and it turned out if he took 33 of those
models you get God to about some
ninety-eight percent of the score that
the 700 models got you to the way the
way we try and protect against that if
we don't run competitions for two years
for starters because then the incentive
is just to layer as a model on top of
model on top of model and the other
thing we do is we try not wad prize
money to the top five so that this is
this comes back to the questions even
asked before about you know that
sometimes the case because we have this
issue of the winner sometimes being a
lottery it's fairer when you award prize
money the top five but these side effect
of doing that is that you also end up
the company that hosts the competition
gets all the models gets all the models
they pay prize money for so they get a
selection and one might be more easily
implementable and so that's how we get
around that issue question of that yeah
certainly becoming a bit more like that
with some of the competitions that
require deep learning or convolutional
neural networks so what's dip what's
often happening for those competitions
is people are doing most of the work on
their own machines and then they'll go
the last mile on you know the Amazon ec2
which give you gpgpu instances for
instance so that that's something we're
seeing a little bit more of question
and so the question was we must have
turned away some some problems as
competitions and I think the generally
to the extent that we turn away problems
it's really because they're not well
enough specified so very often we have a
lot of inbound from companies that want
to get started in data science but we're
actually a relatively more advanced
solution so we end up you don't Google
very you don't have to wait you don't
have to spend too much time googling
before you land on kagal and so if
you're sort of trying to get started in
with data science as a company you
probably come across us but we're
probably not the right fit so I'd say we
we turn away the vast majority the
problems we turn away because or or just
the amount of work to get it to a
specified problem it's just a lot of
work a well specified problem which
actually actually goes well towards the
next thing I was going to talk about so
I might I might close on questions for a
little bit and just talk a little bit
more about one of the things that well
some of the another lesson another key
lesson at Kaggle and one of the things
we're working on as a result so you know
what we found is CAD was really
competitions are a really good solution
for this part of the the machine
learning pipeline except data science
involves a lot more so you start off
you've got to set up your environment
extract data load your day to explore
the problem clean the data and so on and
so forth there's actually know if anyone
follows the big data bar at Twitter
handle but he has this quote the data
science is eighty percent cleaning the
data and twenty percent complaining
about cleaning the data yeah so what we
had developed internally was we
developed some collaboration tooling
that made it much easier for our team
internally to the extent that work
helped consulting with customers and
helping them get their their problems in
shape made it easier to build off what
they had done previously and meant that
we were able to massively condense down
the amount of grunt
work that we were doing internally and
this this has a couple of effects
firstly it makes data science more
enjoyable to do doing less repeating of
data cleaning steps that have been done
before but it also made our team a lot
more productive and so one thing we've
we've started doing is we started
actually releasing this collaboration
tooling into into cattle for people to
use alongside their competitions and
I'll show you what this looks like in a
minute that the idea here is that if
you're yeah if you're competing at the
moment it's it's it's really aimed at
sort of fostering collaboration one of
the key motivations for people coming to
carol and spending as much time on cable
is actually not to win in a lot of cases
but to to learn and so we've started off
by launching this collaboration tooling
into into cablecom wear anything that
it's used for shared publicly but we
will have you know just like github we
will have more private versions as well
so you know attempt to show you a live
demo so for anyone who hasn't been to
cabled up capable for this is what the
website looks like 11 type of
competition we have is a getting started
competition i'm going to show you a
short hands who's seen the amnesty to
set before it's a very common first data
set for for people to try how when
they're doing machine learning I've
asked that question before and I've I
have been given the answer that not only
do I know the M&S data set but I can
actually tell you which individual
digits are very hard to classify so the
M&S data set for those who don't know is
is a handwriting recognition data set
very very typically used to benchmark a
new machine learning algorithms and we
use it as I said as a getting started
competition just to get people in and
and playing with cargill and and if you
want to be cynical I to get people
addicted to kegel and then working on
some of the other competitions and so
one thing that we have fun Cavill that's
really incredibly young credibly popular
feature of the side or our forums and
what we've noticed is that a lot of
people in our forums will share code
so if you want to get ping pays
convolutional neural network code
running you've got to install pandas
scikit-learn matplotlib numpy nolan and
lasagna so yeah you've got to have the
same version of Python so he might be
using 3.4 and you've got two point seven
there's a whole lot of frictions in
downloading his code getting it running
in your environment with that data set
and so on and so forth so what we
launched really only a couple of months
ago as we launched a tool called scripts
and so what you can do is you you might
have noticed scripts is a link just
under forums and when you go into new
script you can choose an hour Python
Julia or our markdown environment the
data is automatically read in and you
can immediately start coding and when
you hit the Run button it will run
inside a docker container on our servers
now as I mentioned anything you use the
scripts tool for is shared publicly and
so for any competition that's running
now you can see or most competitions
they should say you can see what the
highest voted scripts are so you can see
on the right hand side you've got the
number of votes you can also see what
language it was written in so in this
case it's Python you can see how many
Forks how many views so i'm going to
show you one of the ones that i really
like it's written by one of my
colleagues so it's a it's a random
forest and what it's doing is he's
classifying the digits using a random
forest and then he's plotting the
proximity of the digits on an XY plot so
you can see here the nines are really
close to each other the sevens are close
to each other the falls are close to
each other you can see that the nines
and the seventh of near each other the
falls and the nines are near each other
so it's it's working as you might expect
the other thing you might notice is that
he's consistently getting wrong the ones
in bright red are the ones he's getting
wrong who's consistently getting wrong
the sevens with the dashes through them
that one and this one is probably being
mistaken for a nine you can see how it's
group near the nines so if I want to
improve on this I can just hit the fork
button and what it does is it Forks the
docker container so you have the same
environment that he's working in you
have the it Forks the code and it Fox
the connection to the data so it gives
you an environment immediately that you
can sort of take his code and start
working in so we've seen all sorts of
interesting things we have a an overall
scripts page which shows you all the
scripts that have been run across all
the competitions I'm just showing you
the highest voted so not terribly
surprising the the the the scripts that
help you get really good squirrels in
competitions a forked many many times
and also uploaded many many times and so
Abhishek is I think our number three or
number four ranked user yeah question
yeah that's exactly right yeah so it's
in it's an environment it's basically an
online environment to execute code
against the data sets without so yep so
for the time being you can't customize
your own we will release we're adding
functionality to this really really
quickly for the moment you can't you can
only run the with the libraries that we
have installed but we have all the
libraries you could well anything
non-mainstream sorry anything mainstream
that you could possibly want and
actually one of the interesting things
about scripts one of the most popular
uses you'll see that the fourth most
upvoted script is this person are
demonstrating the XG boost model which
is an implementation of gradient
boosting machines so this person think
it's thien key from memory has uh no
sorry somebody else and this person is
the creator of the XP boost library and
they want to promote this library and so
it's a really good way for them to
it's a really good way for them to city
give people the opportunity to play with
their new library and get adoption for
their new library and so what people
like that will typically do is they'll
write to us and they'll say I want to
create a script can you add my library
to your environment so we're constantly
adding new libraries actually one of the
one of the most popular uses for the
scripts tool is exactly that so at the
moment there's about four or five
packages that are competing to be the
the scikit-learn of deep learning
there's Karis lasagna neon a bunch of
them and you'll notice that although if
you scroll down the list you'll notice
here's the lasagna one does Karis there
you go Karis the deep Nets data code so
France was sure let is the creator of
the carers package he uses Kaggle
scripts partly just 22 yeah he wants to
be the psychic learn of you know you can
be the psychic learn of of deep learning
and it's a really good way for people to
be able to play with with françoise's
code where's that oh yeah right
yep we've got mixed results some people
are very happy so the question was what
are the correct me if I'm getting this
wrong but what are the soap social
dynamics around frogging so we're
getting we're getting two sets of
results some people are delighted so to
pick a lot of the people who spend time
on cattle really to learn which is
probably the majority of our user base
are really happy it's a phenomenal
learning opportunity it's a very easy
way to get into somebody else's code
going if you want to play with Charis
there's no easier way to do it on the
flip side we are getting people who are
somewhat annoyed when say Abhishek for
instance post code that will get you a
very very high score on the leaderboard
so you can see here that ash exco gets
your point five seven if you if you were
if your score was a point five six you
suddenly have 136 people ahead of you so
that's the that's the one issue we've
had in launching script so on balance we
think it's a would say sorry to show you
this quickly so you can actually submit
to a competition directly from from
scripts you don't actually have to
download the data but on balance we
think it's healthy for notwithstanding
the fact that we are getting some
pushback from from from people who who
thinks it blunts the competitiveness of
competent competitions what we find is
that the best scripts typically get you
to a certain point that they're not
getting you do know top 20 20 finish and
and on balance we think it's a positive
thing for the site question yeah so it's
a it's in a we're running them in
containers so they're sort of secure
you're worried about you you're asking a
question about running arbitrary code on
our servers and what the impacts know
there are darker containers yeah they're
not arbitrary docker containers not yet
we want that we do want to allow people
to customize their docker containers but
we're not there yet
I know so we're actually little a
traditional for the bay area where we
run on Microsoft Azure but the same as
AWS 0 what people have said that it's
been a powerful way for them to get into
competitions faster I don't know that
we've only been going for two months we
haven't run that many competitions in
that two month period so I don't it's
too early it's it probably is making a
difference but it's too early for us to
have be able to measure it any other
questions the back
so is the question is a way facilitating
is the ID
yep so the question is is this intended
more just to facilitate learning or is
this meant to be a more powerful
instance than people have access to on
their local machine so at the moment
it's just the fourth performer it's only
a learning tool we limit you to a
certain amount of memory we learnt limit
you to I think 10 minutes worth of
execution time so it's not a it's not
it's not what you could buy a much
bigger instance from amazon or
potentially even have a bigger machine
locally and actually we sort of done
that for a reason one of the reasons is
we we will allow people that as I said
arbitrary docker instances larger larger
virtual machines we will support all of
that the reason we haven't started with
it is we want to see people using it
because the tooling is good and it's
nice to use and it facilitates learning
not just because we're giving you a free
way to execute very large code or giving
you more compute than you might
otherwise get I think what we'll start
to do is to then we're giving people
access to more compute people will pay
you'll pay for the will give you a
certain amount for free and then you'll
pay for additional compute the idea is
also that will make this available once
we're at the moment it's a pretty new
product you can only use it in a
cloud-based IDE we haven't we have an
integrated Jupiter notebooks yet well
this is something that is under very
active development and once we get it to
a point where it's it's really it's
really a bit quite a bit further along
than it is will allow people to bring
their own data sets which you can either
share publicly and share your analysis
publicly or or potentially just share
with people you're collaborating with
and the idea is that your cable profile
you can store just like you github
profile you can store a lot more other
data science that you're doing not just
competitions question
yeah so is the execution time an issue
for competition hosts yeah um so what's
typically the case is like the netflix
prize example i gave where it was 700
models ensembles and you could shrink
them down to three and you got pretty
much the same level of accuracy that's
typically the case with the winning
solution so we we have tended not to
give restrictions on execution time but
rather what will typically happen at the
end of a competition is there'll be some
consulting between the winning team and
the competition host and so you can pair
the model back and get it to fit within
the requirements of a customer and we
found that we found keeping the the
objective function for competitions to
be simpler to be a better more more
engaging way to run competitions I think
certainly now that we have scripts it it
increases the range of options that we
have as far as standard you know
requiring execution time is hard to
insist on or it's hard to have execution
time thresholds when everybody's using
different hardware but if everyone's
running on the same hardware that
becomes easier to police but it hasn't
been a big you can typically take
whatever algorithm wins and strip it
down and not really sacrifice very much
in performance that typically isn't such
a big issue how are we doing for time
any other questions yep
yeah we actually don't one thing that
where we have been probably a little bit
slow on and we do want to do more of is
make more of our data the metadata or
the more of our database public and a
stack exchange to a really nice job of
this they have a tool called sequel
explore our where you can query all the
stack exchange data we'd actually like
to make it all available through scripts
eventually so that you can you can
either query it using sequel queries or
you can you can play with it using our
own Python and because if we you know
there's probably a lot of interesting
learnings that we as a team just haven't
at the time to chase down and making
that data available I think would be
interesting so that would allow you to
answer questions you know like the kind
of questions that you're wondering about
it goes a question just in front
yeah so I guess the question is how do
we charge accuracy it's obvious for a
binary classification problem but what
about for regression for instance and
the answer to that is we have about 30
or so metrics built into our software
and so actually even in the case of
binary classification we don't always we
actually rarely use miss classification
error which is the percentage correct
and percentage incorrect will typically
use things like area under the receiver
operator the ROC curve but we have we
have yeah we have I think about 30
metrics built into our competition
wizards that a competition host can
select from and actually we've been
meeting for a long time to open source
these metrics because if you think about
it that our metrics code is pounded on
more than probably just about anybody
else's metrics code so there are often
edge cases that metrics code doesn't
necessarily deal well with because our
metrics are so heavily pounded on this
sort of a good gold standard so we keep
intending to open-source them I don't
believe we have yet but it's yeah it's
it's it's like a lot of things coming
question
yeah how do we know yeah it's a really
nice idea it's related to the question
back there you know with some machine
learning problems or easier and some are
harder and what works well and what
doesn't we've run I think we run about
at the moment we're running about 50
kind of normal competitions a year and
then we have we have a product called
Calgary in class where professors host
competitions for their students if we
run about 150 or 200 of those a year so
overall we've run probably around about
600 competitions I'm not sure so we
probably do have enough of a data set to
be able to least do something where the
feature is the data set and the target
variable is the level level of accuracy
I don't know yeah it's something we can
I think there are lots of interesting
both practical and questions of
practical interest in research interests
that will be able to be answered when we
do finally get around to releasing our
dataset publicly question
yeah you know I would always hoped
initially that we would get to the point
where companies could put where data
science would become like like a sport
and the best data scientists would get
paid equivalent to what the best golfers
get paid and it was always sort of a
nice idea I think that um that ends up
being quite difficult so first of all we
have to spend a lot of time companies
can't uh non boarding competitions at a
high enough volume in order to sort of
really push up the prices so really the
motivation for people to compete on
Carroll is actually much less about
prize money than it is about it's it's
really it's mostly learning so people
people it's a prize money is seen as a
bonus the way it was put to me is
keglers prize money is people like
higher prize money competitions not
because they expect to win but because
it's like high stakes poker sort of
something more at the end of it so you
know it would be nice to get to the
point where people could make a real
living on cable but i think it's it's
it's it's not the motivation for four
it's not the main motivation it's really
to learn and it's you know if you're a
beginning data scientist it's a great
way to sort of get exposure to problems
and datasets and solutions and forum
discussion and if you're an advanced
data scientist you know you can try out
karis and you can try out all sorts of
things that are really pushing the
cutting edge of machine learning
question yeah so one carol has a few we
have a few drivers of revenue one is so
really people most competitions for
three reasons one is getting to the
limit of what's possible on a data set
typically a very hard problem the second
is recruiting so Walmart and Facebook
and companies like that will post
problems and they'll interview the top
20 or 30 and the third is promotional
promotional type type things like if
your fico for instance we ever deal with
like oh where they'll host a certain
number of competitions a year in order
to
promote to our user base the other thing
we have is a jobs board so we charge for
all of those things sort of further out
where you know what we think that
there's a there's a good commercial as
well as being a good learning tool we
think there's a good commercial
opportunity around scripts so making it
much easier as i said we that this is
there's a long way to go on this product
and so we're not charging for it
certainly not charging for for public
use that we do believe that it solves
one of the biggest pain points that data
scientists have which is the ability to
collaborate and we believe we will get
to a product that is feature-rich enough
that data scientists will will want to
use and and those in companies will want
to pay for yeah we're limited by the we
have to help competition hosts on board
the question was is there a limit to how
many competitions we can run a year we
have to help competition hosts on board
their competitions and so we have to
data scientists internally who consult
with customers to get their problems
into the right shape and so we're
limited by yes the number of problems
that are that are sort of close enough
that we can hand them to our data
scientists and then the number that they
can put on and at the moment we have
many more data scientists than we have
like the number of competitors potatoes
I've competition is sort of increasing
as Carol becomes more and more popular
so we are trying to increase our than
the throughput and a number of
competitions that we launched yeah there
is I think the challenge is getting them
into a the question into a form where
they're easy enough to where you can
load them onto cattle question at the
back
yeah so question was the distinction
between elegant and elegant solutions
you know one nice thing about again
scripts which as you can tell I'm
excited about I talk about a lot is
whenever people share code you'd be
amazed at how much cleaner it is them
code that is not that is not shared so
what we're what we're seeing so actually
the quality of the code in scripts is
typically pretty nice whereas the
quality of code that gets handed over at
the end of an end of a competition if
it's not forced to run through a tool
where it's being publicly displayed as
much lower quality and so one thing
we're towing a little bit with is the
idea of asking all competition winners
to run neck have their code go up on
scripts at least to the extent that a
competition host will allow and I think
that knowledge will will push people
push people to refactor and to write
need a code question
yeah sorry can you I didn't quite catch
the question
Yeah right right yeah yeah so I guess
our competition host ever disappointed
because solutions are not being simple I
think there's probably more often the
opposite disappointment which is the
solutions are more complex actually I
think the biggest source of
disappointment for competition host
which happens very happened a lot in the
very early days I was on board in
competitions and happened more when i
was doing them then the now but leakage
in in data sets where you put up a you'd
be amazed at the forms of leakage that
are possible in a data set so anytime we
always we have a big checklist of things
that we check for whenever we get a new
data set one example is well an obvious
one mapping row number against the
target variable you'd be amazed at how
often when you get a data set from a
customer and you you correlate Road
number two to the target variable how
often there is a correlation so we have
a lot of things that we check for in
order to try and limit the number of
competitions where leakage is an issue
in you if you've been a long term
category you'll notice that it's
nowadays relatively rare that you see
leakage whereas in the early days it was
a it was a pretty acute problem that's
actually another thing we should
probably release in a blog post is sort
of all the checks we go through to make
sure to make sure our data sets in good
shape you know when one of my colleagues
gave a talk recently at a machine
learning meet up in in Mountain View and
she said she asked the question how many
of you have a thousand or two thousand
people looking at your work well I do so
you know any time she puts out a data
set she you know she knows it's going to
be pounded on and and it has to be
pretty pretty carefully checked before
yeah I think I mentioned the main one
that deep deep deep learning and
compilation additional neural networks
like a lot of things that's been
overhyped but it is a real thing and you
know for anyone who wants to play with
them you know we have a phenomenal we
have a really nice library of of deep
learning and convolutional neural
networks code that you can play with
that's that's the main one that comes to
mind it's not very surprising trying to
think of something more surprising I
think that's yeah question yeah so the
question is we want to get all the
winning competition models in scripts
but is that going to annoy customers who
have paid prize money in order for a
license to the winning code we have
different licensing requirements we have
different pricing tiers so the most
expensive competitions we run are only
open to people of the Masters rank and
if you run that competition at that
price point you get an absolute license
over the winning algorithm and that's
not going to know that's not going to go
in scripts on the other hand we've done
things with Wikipedia for instance and
they want to deal with them to the open
source and so in those situations
absolutely it's fine to put something
into scripts the I guess that the most
common case is a non-exclusive license
is granted to the to the to the customer
in that case we we sort of asked them
we'll ask permission on a case-by-case
basis so and that's more a courtesy than
it is something that we're legally
obliged to do so okay I'll take two more
questions s'alright yep okay
yeah yeah so the question was we
sometimes anonymized data sets before we
put them up online to what extent when
we anonymize the data set is information
last I would say that it's really very
confident definitely the case that
information is lost and it's very
context dependent as to how much
information is lost we always encourage
to the extent possible not to anonymize
not to anonymize data sets because or
anonymize them as little as possible
because definitely degrades the
information content and if you don't
share the if you don't share information
on the rose it makes it harder for
people to be creative with feature
engineering so um it's hard for me to
give a general answer but there is
always information loss well there is
typically information loss the more
heavily you anonymize the data set I'm
going to take one more question yeah so
we did quite a lot of work in in energy
specifically in oil and gas we worked
shell was the first our first oil and
gas customer and what they wanted to do
was they wanted to optimize the
performance of their of their wells
based on things like you know how much
fluid they're injecting and all their
different engineering parameters and we
we'd worked with so turns out that
there's a lot you can do so a lot of
data science at the moment is focused on
things like you know Google predicting
what ads you're going to click on and
Facebook what what you want to see in
your newsfeed but there's a lot of
interesting stuff that can be done in
the physical world as well that's really
an untapped opportunity and we started
working a lot in oil and gas with the
idea that we would sort of branch out
and do more in other industries as well
that where a lot of these techniques
have not yet been penetrated and I think
there are we ended up hitting we ended
up ended up shutting that business
mostly mostly just because of the oil
price and also because more sensible
direction for us to go was more around
the collaboration tooling it's sort of a
better fit with our community and and so
that's that's really where the emphasis
is
for us at the moment and sort of the
next wave of growth for us is really
around scripts and the collaboration
tool I'll take one more question and
then anyone can feel free to come up and
chat afterwards question yeah yeah I
like the essay grading it's one of the
one of the ones it's not a complete
success story yet but it's on the way so
it's been actually been deployed in in a
couple of schools it's taking a long
time I think we did the work in 2012 but
it's it is actually sort of slowly
making its way into schools another one
that we're doing at the moment which i
think is going to turn into a fabulous
success story is around taking images of
the eye and diagnosing an eye disease
called diabetic retinopathy so this is
so the idea diabetic retinopathy is a is
an eye disease that many many diabetics
suffer from and if you can detect it
early it's eminently treatable but
there's a shortage of there's a shortage
of folk who have the ability to
diagnosis I disease and so the
Californian Health Care Foundation are
running a competition at the moment to
take images of the eye and see whether
you can actually diagnose
algorithmically and like with the essay
grading we're at the point where we're
matching human performance so this is
one the other grading is a historical
and the diabetic retinopathy is one that
I think is going to end up making its
way into the field and really having an
impact all right um so we might enter
there and anyone who wants to continue
chatting I'll hang around